[Musique]
mais toi
et
[Musique]
wahaha
à
il faudra
oh
[Musique]
allez
ça s'est passé à des nas autant vous le
dire tout de suite nous on les adore à
mort vous avez pas fini de les voir le
blind test avec smaïn comme c'est
difficile c'est carrément impossible
kid creole august darnell qui chante
dancing in the bains douches au palace
il a accompli le magot koala smaïn qui
revient avec l'auto interview c'est
encore plus dur
patrick besson qui inaugure l'interview
goût du tac au tac rochefort de
challenger de t d à g 10 têtes et des
appâts ppda rochford pas ockrent
le kid relooké par claude challe merci
docteur comme base robert la peinture
aussi ses robes comme merde on fait
quand même un chouchou le jeu le plus
naze de la télé si c'est possible
isaac de bankolé tourada dans la jungle
a dit non c'est super
georges tout le monde les questions les
choses non mais attendez pourquoi je
vais me fâcher avec mathilda may mois et
voit les cinq blacks il en faire quand
tout compris mon pote la table à
moutarde en perfecto vie valls arrive à
pasadena
a exclu lunettes et compagnie le morceau
qui met de bonne humeur le matin
attention on s'accroche
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
hadopi
c'est nous
cela n'enlève
[Musique]
bah
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
m
il
nous
[Musique]
je ne passe pas
mais pas
[Musique]
m
je ne sais pas
aux usa
[Musique]
la peau
et
c'est le genre de fille à lui mais les
mecs à draguer les mecs où elle se fait
draguer je contracte pas du tout je ne
fais pas vrai que c'était le genre de
fille est large et les mecs ou attendre
compte l'âge c'est dur question ça se
passe demain accord commun sur le chemin
avant les grandes discussions ont décidé
de saluer aujourd'hui c'est terminé il
enchaîna je me renseigne
je ne sais pas comment ça se passe
jalouse cmfi vachement ah bon oui je
passe tu trouves ton mec en peinture
possessivité que ces travaux
oui je trouve ton mec en train de se
faire draguer par une paix par exemple
est capable
deux amants fidèles cette finale
idéaliste à bon compte avec un garçon
qui ne trompe pas assez sûr non mais je
suis pas vraiment beaucoup d'expérience
avec paris ça se passe bien d'un jour
qui a mis en boîte tu rencontres à un
sublime mannequin génial c'est vrai tu
de ta vie ressemble jamais quoi si tu as
aimé robin des bois était capable de
craquer non comme tout le monde est
capable de traquer
quand quelqu'un
du mal à y croire mais c'est à la fois
que je peux répondre sous cet angle je
ne garde pas les douze ans j'avais 15
ans que ceux d'hier soir ça m'arrive
fréquemment
ah ben non c'est juste et plus
c'est pourtant d'une pierre tant attendu
parler des questions francs oui on tend
la jambe
oui j'ai même vu
est ce que tu préfères tu en perds ta
mère ça c'est un piège à rat ça c'est
pas possible tu peux pas répondre tu
peux toi je regarde l'émission j'ai
trouvé intelligent de question qu'on
veut passer pour qui tu es le plus en
fait à qui tu trouve le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
ja rule skis watts lynch et a même
consulté le bon soir qu'est ce que tu
veux que je te dise ok je n'ai aucun
talent et 50 ans atténuantes pour
pouvoir à des gens dangereux
source de terrifiant je pense qu'ils
sont aussi pire l'un claude oui aussi
grave question compte les plus facile
maintenant si tu devais partir sur une
île déserte
tu peux faire repartir avec jospin ou
jeux pbj non mais bon il ya des carmes à
la wii
ah bon peut-être parce que tu es
socialiste parce qu'il est mieux équipé
parce qu'il est peut-être oui d'abord
correspond un peu plus ça
donc on vous parle dans les politiques
imagine maintenant c'est la guerre une
espionne été arrêté et puis on dit voilà
on va la voile a tué parce que aucun
droit d'être espion est-ce que tu
préfèrerais être fusil guillotine et ça
aussi c'est très con la question c'est
cool non
fusillé peut-être alors avant fusillait
pourquoi tu penses que celle attendue
c'est pas pareil la composition est ce
que magie non toujours si on me disait
voilà vous rester paralysé toute votre
vie allongé sur un lit en fer en fait
enfermer il y aura plus jamais
d'inondations au bangladesh où les
petits-enfants du bangladesh pourront
manger du riz à leur faim jusqu'à la fin
des temps à peine un oui
non je crois que j'irai jusqu'à me
sacrifier même type et petits-enfants du
bangladesh pouvez vous ferai
idéalement je ferai en pratique dernière
question maintenant parce que de façon
la bombe ariz est ce que c'est la plus
con c'est pas là imagine que voilà un
jour tu allumes la radio en attaque je
travaillais à la radio qui ont dit une
bombe atomique est parti
de quelque part dans une fusée et puis
la bombe arrive en cinq minutes
qu'est ce que tu fais quelles sont les
dernières choses que tu fais quand même
ta mère te fais ton frère tu t'en bois
en l'air qu'est ce que tu veux je crois
que la dernière solution sera le
meilleur
[Musique]
fini les santé dans les 90 et le sampler
qui fait la zik et ça s'appelle la house
music
ça c'est opéra house jack makossa un mec
de nairobi au kenya qui a rencontré un
dj de chicago fatou d'une histoire quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que sam lane test oui je crois
que tu mets les musiques il faut que je
dise que ce avec huawei ont la taille
près pas ton bien
attention le premier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme une intro d'une demi heure on
attend la vie tient alors tu m'excuses
je sais pas c'est la visite de bach en
algérie chez moi mais aussi tout à
l'heure on en a parlé c'est mon coeur
s'ouvre à chanter n'est pas la
clarinette
[Rires]
maman de leur part
ça c'est leur foi
tu connais c'est leur foi ouais ouais
ouais je connais bien calé dans son
émission non pourquoi tu veux pas y
aller
voici ma ville j'y vais et tout cas pas
invité d'honneur et de probité aurait pu
y aller et à la scala de famille d'abord
en lui leur donne moi je prends pas en
parler c'est la différence c'est la
différence wen
suivant un sursis en 48 heures c'est un
peu une vitesse de 70 cm rigueur
berings pour lyon je vois pas s'y attend
pas reconnaître
[Musique]
hello
c'est bizarre c'est la première action
non c'est la deuxième ce n'est pas ça
que je connais la première nation s'est
dit vos satisfactions dans 77 faisant
dit c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
il a fait un plan rap est à vous qui
faisait le morceau dark castle ouais ça
a bien fonctionné
après tout d'appeler de cirmad
d'ailleurs pas bon qu'il était viré de
la télé elle est revenue partenaires
venus en tentant de parra turquie non ça
veut dire fonctionne assez bien
alors là c'est bien aussi bien mais
c'est peut-être un peu plus dur à
trouver
76 toujours toujours new york un peu ce
qu'ils murmurent je sais moi laissez les
musiques américaines s'est pas mis le
devenu international mais toi tu connais
mais c'est pas lui c'est un mec avec un
chapeau blanc super sympa et man dp
derrière ce qui attend les salariés
parce qu'à l'époque chez des pâquis
à l'époque ça s'appelait savannah bande
des trucs dans cette émission mais
j'aime beaucoup disent et culturel s'est
jamais cette chronique américain
maintenant c'est la fin la musique de
mon spectacle
ca c
ce 8e ging mais le projet je suis fou
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
walt est allé sur la place paul segade
ou le cadeau d'un jouet
je suis de bâle bâle bâle bonne humeur
ce matin reste en lapin ça c'est là et
je suis sûr qu'il fait exprès non son
attaque dans mon spectacle je ne savais
plus mobile est et s'il allait dessiner
bien sûr et ça cartonne
très fort tu vois en main tous les soirs
surtout je crois je sais pas si oui nous
voir si elle est tellement cassé mes
potes je le vois stups et aubin tous les
soirs 1 pourquoi tu gobain tous les
soirs moi parce que c'est pas du théâtre
mais je sors
tous les soirs je vais voir un petit
robot et moi je me couchais devrait
pâtir a déménagé tête non mais je crois
que j'étais pro du palace change pas de
ma bb lunettes et cetera continue de
plus belle avec les informent crosson et
florentin faut-il coucher pour devenir
une star
elles sont toutes passées par là en
dévoilant leur charme alors aujourd'hui
comment devenir star quand on est
inconnu répondant lunettes noires avec
cette superbe imposture le cinéma c'est
peut-être tout simplement une question
de q monsieur danon que pensez vous des
récentes mesures du ministère de la
culture et la communication visant à
réduire le nombre de films à la
télévision un décret venant d'être
publié dans le journal officiel du 13
septembre ce qui implique pas plus de
deux films aux heures de grande écoute
pour chaque chaîne et ce à partir de
quelle est votre réaction eh bien
ma réaction est que ce n'est pas en
réduisant la quantité de films qui
passent à la télévision que l'on va
résoudre les problèmes de l'industrie
cinématographique française ne t'ont pas
partisans de sanctions envers les
chaînes qui ne respecteraient pas ces
nouveaux quotas de diffusion
ça c'est différent s'il ya une
réglementation et le faites pour être
respectées
voilà je suis contre la réglementation à
partir du moment où elles existent je
considère qu'il faut la respecter
le cinéma français se porte bien
aujourd'hui non il se porte pas bien du
tout à ce propos comment apprendre
appréhendez-vous pardon la récente
polémique qui a eu lieu au festival de
deauville entre le film américain et le
film français en un mot et vous êtes
vous en accord à tes propos de daniel
toscan du plantier à savoir que les
films américains ne sont que des
produits ce qui se fit bas ça va pas
qu'est ce qu'on seule escale en coupe ce
cas bien
bien en mettre partout même du talent ce
n'est pas la chaîne va me faire faire
des essais et si vous voulez bien va
signer quelque chose comme ça les
démange
est ce que vous êtes d'accord et toscan
du plantier je m'excuse j'ai pas à
partager pas vu cette émission j'ai
entendu beaucoup parler et j'ai pas
d'unité attention à votre nom était
encore troublé par ouï pas nous engager
[Musique]
j'ai passé pas d'appel dans mon bureau
mais ça peut déranger les gens merci sur
reversade à mon nom c'était à moi de
commencer
monsieur saada que pensez vous des
récentes mesures du ministère de la
culture et la communication visant à
réduire le nombre de films à la
télévision un récent décret venant
d'être publié au journal officiel du 13
septembre ce qui implique pas plus de
deux films
aux heures de grande écoute pour chaque
chaîne et ce à partir de 1989
je ne suis pas persuadé que c'est
vraiment malgré tout seriez vous plutôt
partisans de sanctions envers les
chaînes qui ne respecteraient pas ces
nouveaux quotas de diffusion comme une
sanction
il ya donc des mesures gouvernementales
on sent que les les ministres en
question où va le faire aboutir la
question mais pour vous est ce que le
cinéma français se porte bien en 88 est
ce qu'il est en bonne santé
tout est en bonne santé parce qu'il y
ait deux aspects différents pour revenir
au cinéma ce que vous trouvez normal que
certains réalisateurs soit aujourd'hui
contraint de s'exiler généralement aux
états unis pour pouvoir réaliser
confortablement et normalement leurs
films la principale cause étant
justement la manque de capitaux des
producteurs français
justement je crois que le faux débat
est-ce qu'il n'existe pas quand même une
sorte de guerre entre le film américain
le film français
non mais qu'est-ce qui se passe on
trouve là non mais non mais ce jour il
ya dix ans notre reportage mais on
continuera
j'ai vu mon père est vraiment à sa
suppression chef bilbault soir mais
aucun problème c'est pour vous montrer
maman je suis prête à tout bon non je ne
mange pas vraiment étonnant
non mais d'accord je trouve très
sympathique moi ça ouais et du langage
auriez pourquoi pas c'est vrai qu'en
actuelle l'express vous compare à une
humeur fille coluche
ça vous fait quoi ça me fait peur
coluche le luron des proches ont disparu
et son accent maintenant vous n'avez pas
un peu qu on devrait tous avoir peur
c'est plus place foch avec les ppp
depuis que vous êtes une star non plus
difficile pourquoi parce que elles sont
l'impression que je me fais pas de tp
elle veut être peut-être paraître plus
original vous fait quoi comme tête quand
quand vous les fait rire une pp j'essaie
d'être le plus sincère possible
et puis il arrive un moment où je
récupère en sortant ivan alors là
monsieur s'attendent tout de suite comme
les chevaux si un homme dans la rue
comme ça vous accostent se retourne
quand ils eurent et vous dites sales
arabes
quelle est votre réaction à manger de
plâtre de rire parce que je trouve que
c'est pas du tout original
puis je passe mon chemin je dis toi même
on dit que deux heures d smaïn
équivalent à un vrai colloque anti
raciste mais harlem désir dit que vous
avez difficilement assumer votre rôle de
beurre j'aime pas les porte drapeaux
vous avez dit donc dans un des journaux
parus vient vous avez dit que vous ne
savez pas si votre père était militaire
français juif ou arabe selon vous votre
propre conviction
d'où venez vous c'est difficile de
répondre à ça parce que tu sais pas
comment les gens peuvent le prendre
je crois que je suis fils d'un homme
c'est tout et je crois que puis surtout
le fils d'une femme qui m'a ému quoi
puisque l avoue il a bien voulu de moi
c'est important
une solution sur le champ pour la
solution il ya un seul autre sens
étaient choisis laquelle j'aurais choisi
les trois on vous dit que la france
s'est irrévocablement métissé est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que ça aurait été une
chance pour l'algérie
porter un regard sur l'algérie c'est
difficile pour moi dans la mesure où
c'est à la fois mon pays c'est à la fois
mon identité à la fois c'est aussi mon
absence donc
je suis allé en algérie j'ai lu ce pays
merveilleux et je suis entièrement
d'accord avec cette idée que l'algérie
devait avoir son indépendance parce que
c'était de toute manière le cours de
l'histoire
et ça c'est pas un militaire c'est pas
un homme qui a vécu la guerre d'algérie
je les curetons victimes
je crois que c'était le cours de
l'histoire maintenant le métissage je
souhaite qu'un jour cette terre soit le
métissage qu'il y ait un métissage total
c'est certain parce que je crois que
c'est dans le métissage d'abord quatre
beaux enfants
et puis aussi c'est l'échangé des
billets qui des cultures de nouveau un
conflit entre la france et l'algérie
notre position laquelle je serai du côté
des gens qui pleurent
quels étaient les personnages comiques
qu'il vous fait exploser de rire mais
vraiment vraiment retourné de rire
après vous qui m'éclate de rien mes
copains question grave
néanmoins amusante quand même est-ce que
vous pensez que l'on pourrait faire
éclater de rire
jean-marie le pen non aylwin 4 est rien
vous avez tous les femmes l'argent les
impôts à payer
qu'est-ce qu'il vous ferait plaisir
maintenant je ne sais pas
dites moi quoi à lui d'abord j'ai pas
tout ce que je voulais attention un
moment ce que je voudrais maintenant
c'est continue ma petite vie sympa
la continuer simplement avoir évidemment
des enfants mais j'ai peut-être attendre
je sais pas je voudrais que les gens ne
prennent simplement comme moi je les
prends simplement et peut-être
en tout cas le regard que je porte en
tout cas sur mon métier c'est que mon
plaisir l'idée de sur scène soit élevée
par la maintenance la question - cha
milliards du mia quoi il ya plein de
médias qui tu fais avec ma j'irai pour
ce que je ferais je produire des films
et puis j'essaie de concrétiser ce que
j'aime le plus le cinéma produire des
émissions de télé découvrir des jeunes
talents etc pour pour avancer pour
continuer
alors voilà le seul truc un peu nouveau
cette année c'est les rappeuses ailleurs
après roxane chantier avance aux tempi
fà voici deux frangines d'enfer de oui
papa girl et qui tape
oui papa ou une maman oui toi
[Musique]
sarkozy
m
[Musique]
jusqu'ici
là
[Musique]
ban
avec besson tu va inaugurer une nouvelle
forme d'interviews et je vais te
balancer un certain nombre devant
propres et à chaque fois qu'il a mené
par action je commence avec pouchkine
par hasard
un adolescent au teint mat marchand
triste que l'anglais temps et nous
obsède depuis ce temps le bruit si léger
de ses parts c'est le héros de temps
dernier roman qui s'appelle la statue de
la description par anna akhmatova
d'alexandrie avait du punch qui n'ont
peu héros de mon roman
nathalie pouchkine à sa famille quelques
conseils naissent de la fressange oui
oui elle ressemble beaucoup à l'aise
c'était une grande fille brune très
belle comme ça très bien fait très
amusant eugène onéguine ce vieil aux
gènes et ben c'est le titre du roman en
vers de pouchkine ou pouchkine à 25 26
ans annonce sa mort en duel cirque la
mort du poète lenski en duel contre
eugène onéguine c'est la mort de
pouchkine contre georges dantès le
supposé amant de sa femme mais je refuse
cette version est en test n'a jamais
couché avec nathalie bouche maurice
boudeulle offre un opéra rock
roland leroy relanceront attends tu buzz
gratos pour lui enfin pour lui et pour
tous les vices de l'humanité qu'il est
jolie malika rojas et huawei
j'espère moi j'avais jamais lu tes
papiers dans l'humanité mais j'avoue
qu'ils sont très drôles
bah oui mais j'encourage vivement mais
s'ils veulent pas acheter l'humanité ils
sont édités chez messidor de temps en
temps en temps on en a fait un il ya un
an qui s'appelait amicalement rouge et
laon fonds d'emprunt bientôt qui
s'appellera intifada gorbatchev un bon
russe sac à main parce que tu t'étonnes
comprennent toujours des nouvelles de la
santé de sakharov et puis pas d et pas
les ouvriers vont manifestement à la
santé de sa carole va mieux sur la
félicite pour lui pour la femme et pour
tout virus parce que c'est un homme
intéressant ce problème évidemment c'est
un type qui a inventé la bombe atomique
russe a travaillé dessus ça va musée à
l'époque les gens réclament la
libération d'un type dont il craignait
qu'on leur envoie la bombe
la chance m'a dit je suis ravi qu'il
soit libre et heureusement ja rule est
ce qui compte il prononce savent gérer
les skis comme avons fait ce qui na waie
si tu attends c'est un type avec des
lunettes noires
jean-marie voir le roi des animaux
ouais mais tu te fais peu plus de 8 pb à
west figaro un peu c'est vrai que tu es
déjà deux appartements
ouais comment tu as fait pour que les
deux attentats dont me dit non tu me
rond-point sur l'ailleurs demande - et
la transparence quand chers amis quelle
transparence et reste aux écarts
rien absolument rien ils devraient
relire le livre de gorbatchev
il n'y a pas un mot sur les appartements
avant ils disent pas comment il
s'appelle natural c'est la triste saison
de la télé qu'il lui semblait habiter
là-bas nimier mais on m'a toujours plu
pour 1 us à moi ils sont plutôt sailly
labourse du couscous et sérieux à cause
du charbon et et a fait la guerre de
respect moi j'étais en allemagne en
espagne à l'époque où il faisait la
guerre c'est à dire en allemagne parce
que j'ai occupées mamadou bah c'est
drôle parce que je rachète tous ses
livres en ce moment je les fais reliés
mais je les relis plus éric me montmurat
qu'isabelle adjani tout feu tout flamme
la madone ta mère un buzz se lève
michael jackson chirurgie esthétique
générale
mais à vue de nez prince ben un copain
et huawei des pda
ah oui alors c'est le type de la
banlieue de londres qui a réussi là où
beaucoup ce qui fait mauvais pda
alors oui c'est un type de la banlieue
ouest derrière dix ans alors là je peux
te dire vraiment ce bâtiment mais quand
même c'est bon écrivain malgré tout
malgré tous ses défauts mais c'est aussi
le sens de mon lit l'essence de mon
livre c'est qu'un écrivain il faut être
tout ce qu'il veut
c'est un bon écrivain moi je suis parent
donne toujours tout
[Musique]
woodson alias rochefort pour les vrais
grands des métiers première partie de
tété d assas et du rythm'n blues mon
pote ça s'appelle qu'ed whitacre
[Musique]
à gagner
1 0
son match
[Musique]
les gars
c'est
[Musique]
quand
mais
[Applaudissements]
non
là
[Musique]
qui ça
et
quand même
[Musique]
brundle
modèle
[Musique]
je vais
non
le jeu
aucun dégât
[Musique]
camus
du mois
à temps
[Musique]
oui
tout l'état
le candidat
et
[Musique]
là
m
l'affairé
[Musique]
ouais
[Rires]
dr les assistantes aux médias d'état
alors qu'elle lui avait fait all about 1
d'abord auguste a été le pied de la bile
et ça mais quand il fait beau
d'abord il est beau il est sympa et puis
ça m est un jeu que je suis sûr que même
ont stipulé les gants les mecs et nous
habiller de jeu du rock'n'roll
ouais alors ça c'est vrai il a toujours
été pris william moore n'est plus les
vêtements les plus beaux toujours été
sûr ça a été un plaisir de la vie la
hisse tout est ok alors nous avons
trouvé un look qui normalement c'est pas
c'est pas le sien mais je crois qu'il
peut il peut la voir sur scène il faut
la voie pour sortir alors l'oeil
assemble le char pour les chapeaux alors
il ya japon à d'abord on remercie jean
paul gaultier parce que nous en prêter
des vêtements de la saison prochaine
ouais t'as damidot premières toiles et
boire et un scoop complaire à l'orias
chapeau de jean-paul ouais y'a stephen
améliorée avec des franches il ya alors
il ya un blouson de cuir qui est super a
besoin de collection qui vient de chez
de chez besco ce qu'on faisait au marché
malik et puis cela n'est plus bon nous
on a une fortune ils sont sublimes
alors on va l'enlever parce qu'on va
voir le reste voilà ça peut compliquer
non mais voilà très bien matthew smith
nelly please
alors là il fait leur lie à une chemise
ça c'est le chemise western
d'authentiqués des petites broderie la
des vrais broderies art devient vient du
d'un cowboy dream est le favori mais le
western sahara le
le petit jolie botha ces deux
collections jean paul aussi gauthier
alors la veste le costume d'aya la
petite veste avec le petit chat chape ce
qu'on appelle sa chape sacha cache le
pantalon sa cage et jay les cobayes
protège qui gardait les vaches voilà
alors ça ça vient de chez nous et c'est
encore et encore du jeu jean paul
toujours alors les petits accessoires
c'est aussi jean paul petit revolver qui
font pas de mal à personne sans jusqu'à
pour le look cédé révèle vernis aux
oreilles d'un revolver newell bien sûr
le plaisir il y avait le parapluie ça
aussi c'est un revolver newedge est à
dire que tu donnes que de l'amour elle
protège de la pluie près du soleil qui
tu vois alors et les pompes ça vient
d'eux alors le jeans ce qui est très
beau le disent tous ces pages il normal
chez cimarron simard très bonne maison
espagnole
superbe qu est ce qu il yad autres ah
oui a les boules qui nous feraient alors
les bulls a même failli là il a joui tu
t'es pas d'accord mais vous lafakis mary
jean regarde si on dit qu elles vont
l'adorer comme ça les copains on
l'adorait devant lui violé des boots et
pas des bouts de sauvegarde succès
récents thierry ça vaut 100 diack savons
pas ce que les boots ont un peu chaud
devrait aussi là on est conforme à la
maison qui fait ok avec contrôle d'une
file
oui mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui deviennent comme standard du monde
c'est le baby nos hôpitaux micola
[Musique]
bon
pis toé
etc
tactique
[Musique]
et puis thomas
non
quand
oui
[Musique]
pepito
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
et puis thomas
[Musique]
et là
et non
[Musique]
hélas
[Applaudissements]
non
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans mes parents
[Musique]
et demi
robert combas à quel âge as-tu su que tu
étais un pâtre à deux ans avant tout un
aperçu comment parce que je dessine et
ouais c'est par un kim eng foncée mét en
premier tableau a quel âge elle tint à
quel âge tu a explosé à quel âge tu es
devenu connu d
médias du public et galeries à 23 ans
c'est quoi vittel plus influencé à ton
avis qu on tape un tueur célébrions
wilson ah bon le chanteur des beach boys
ah bon c'est lui qui fait le plus
influencé ne pas sourire plus qu'aucun
autre patrouille parce que picasso près
ce quota mais franchement ça figure je
trouve vraiment un petit patick qu'elle
porterait m s'ils n'étaient pas robert
combas sûrement un peintre maudit parce
que c est parce qu on est on est né au
20e siècle on peut plus l'être ont été
copiés déjà beaucoup par qui mais par
beaucoup de groupes de peinture copier
disant mjc ouais j'sais pas moi je dis
d'ailleurs il ya des gens qui de pompes
pas bien sûr qui parle
j'espère qu'ils sont pas là vous non
musulmanes fut main par exemple quand
même tu pense avoir apporté quoi la
peinture je suis de montagne c'est tout
mais je suis le premier à l'avoir fait
quoi qu'est-ce qui a inventé la
figuration libre sous toit jeudi rosa
c'est moi c'est toi
mathieu di rosa à l'époque on faisait de
la bande dessinée peintures et moi je
devais nature on pourrait dire que vu le
nombre de peintres qui nous copient
maintenant on pourrait dire qu'aulas et
21,5
quand même tu es quand même temps pour
faire un tableau
havas était plus court 3 heures
maintenant je mets à peu près deux jours
deux jours
tu vis bien de la peinture je vis
normalement c'est combien par mois peut
pas pourquoi j'étais sûr qu'on allait
vous vous posez ces questions là je n'ai
pas trahi tommy à 40 me et en marchant
et de prendre combien de temps tableau
70 pour ça non c'est beaucoup quand même
non et oui on voit pas ce qui était
avancé de l'argent l'époque où tu étais
pas connu simplement comme ça comme ça
d'abord parce que j'aimerais qu'ils
travaillent sérieusement alors je leur
donne le plus de moyens possible de
travailler bien pour que je sois qu'est
ce qu'ils font avec cet argent parce qu
on a les problèmes un principe pour ça
il faut leur demander
en tout cas souhaité y penser c'est la
vérité on peut les voir où tes tableaux
en ce moment dans la galerie lambert et
la galerie et bobo la galerie nan c'est
la même il faut aller surtout voir les
toiles parce que les adaptateurs ne se
voit pas à la télé ça se voit bien sûr
un vrai
[Musique]
c'est assez rare
faye sayans la bombe at-on soena
alors à votre avis la cdu quoi qu'elle
chante là les pépés lassé des italiennes
les grecs dé la marque sd liechtenstein
sd pays basque on savait rien de moi je
vous donne la réponse à la fin d'accord
du tout
obama
[Musique]
attendu et le cas
c'est pas ici
bien que je
[Musique]
m
en laissant ce qu'elle
sont sur mon avis
[Musique]
c'est pas là
c'est gratuit
quel sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour maria
[Musique]
si la saed
c
pour maria
[Musique]
c'est pas salé
dil
[Musique]
pas vous
madness plus
thomas
[Musique]
m
en effet si ça
ces jeunes
pas
[Musique]
comme ça
ça
[Musique]
cazaux lingers elles seront bientôt au
new morning à mars alors j'ai toujours
pas trouvé bande de naze c'est des
lapines na dé la panne pas plus des
finlandaises à vous y êtes presque sauf
que on dit les chinoises et c'est du
rock finlandais
il cherche moins à hitler jeune homme
blond nous vis de sa maîtresse eva moi
je n'oublie pas de tirer la ficelle et
tout se passera très bien ce match comme
une citrouille pourri au maire de carvin
eyed peas algues bleues si je me trompe
jeunes gens en ce moment en europe c'est
la guerre
ça fait une semaine au lieu d'attaquer
des bateaux allemande vous ne faites que
bouaké dormi une ligne accueillons
moment sopa grossière c'est pas gênant
de devenir le noir de service du cinéma
français un peu quand maintenant disons
ce serait gênant si si l'utilisation de
ça se fait dans une mouvance deux mois
de mai quand je dire on se sert de la
mode pour essayer d'ouvrir notre chemin
et notre cheminement qui est personnel
ça me dérange pas alors ton père a
trouvé à trois épouses la polygamie
c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse
vraiment de 17 ce qui m'intéresse cet
échec
non non tu en rêves ça ne me choque pas
je rêve pas spécialement et j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi dans une situation
donnée on amenait à créer une structure
qui favorise une catégorie et qui les
favorisent une autre fois que ces cds
mois encore incendies favorisés les
femmes noires du point de vue de
l'occidentale où il n'est pas de mon
point de vue je veux dire il faudrait
rendre un peu plus là dedans pour voir
aussi d'autres mécanismes qui sont les
mécanismes quand tu retournes la bête
est choqué par ce genre de choses
je suis choqué par devenir la nouvelle
génération de femmes noires qui
utilisent ces genres de choses pour
démanteler un système qui n'est pas
forcément négatif tout entier alors au
festival de cannes tu as eu un problème
au carlton en tapas laisser rentrer
parce que tu avais pas le bon bah depuis
une affaire comme ça alors est-ce que tu
passes ça fait 13 ans que tu es en
france est-ce que tu réellement à
souffrir d'actes de racisme
je crois que tout un chacun à partir du
moment où on a je sais pas on les bat
nike et qui mal placé que que la
majorité on se trouve un peu
marginalisés comme ça mais je crois que
justement là la force des gens qui sont
marginalisés c'est d'essayer de te
disais ça pour pour casser toutes les
barrières mais ça peut être un avantage
quand même des avantages je crois qu'il
faut quand il faut la transformer pour
en faire une force
c'est vrai j'ai souffert de certaines
réactions mais j'ai toujours essayé de
mettre ça sur le compte de la bêtise
humaine
je crois que c'est plus facile mais est
ce que tu es
inquiet de la montée en france quand
même d'un électorat dix ans
d'extrême droite qui peut se montrer
raciste souvent je suis inquiet de cette
montée si s'il n'y a pas de paravent
syli à dire s'il ya des tas de gens qui
sont contre cette montée justement qui
se met en face de cette montée mais je
suis très content que ça ressort parce
que je veux tout ce qui est souterrain
un beau jour ou l'autre ça éclate et
autant je veux dire affronter le mal
d'événements si le pen faisait chez pas
en france un jour
51% des voix s p tueur est invité aux
états unis où qui retournera en afrique
quand j'entendrai par les 50% je crois
que bien avant je suis revenue en force
dans les combien moi j'avais tablé sur
les élections présidentielles est comme
ça avec les accords entre
la droite purement droite et est située
cette dérive droitière et je m'étais dit
ici dépasse s'ils atteignent 25 % je
crois que je prendrai mes cliques et mon
coach partir est différente nous
l'espérons pour l'avenir de tous
que ceux qui me fasse partie de la
demande anticipée
[Musique]
ça
ceci me jean yves allaire qu on
applaudirait fort la deuxième candidate
à ces marie france il neige herriot
sauvé la vie parisienne qu'on applaudit
vous oublier
hélas elle prépare quelque chose
justement je ploie que maintenir la
qualité du corps dans sa croissance hors
des studios j'ai enregistré avec le
dynamisme de la première question
concerne la divine dibango technique
voilà un peu marginale continent la plus
gros gros tout terrain alors dans le
film
en général elle faisait déjà 130 kg à la
vie très bon qui sait mais dans ce film
quand il était habillé en femme
qu'est ce que tout le monde sait je
serai je suppose de super g un mec dans
ce film elle était habillée et il
faisait 140 100 kg oui mais bien la
réponse qu'il aurait plus que son poids
réel pourquoi c'est ça met des gros
seins non non non attendez ça je sais
pas tant ses talons
j'ai vu cette intrigue anglais allemand
et allons renforcer parce que c'est
tellement fort qu'il avait peur de ce
que ces dix centimètres qu'elle faisait
pas exprès pour supporter son poids
effectivement bonne question
à la deuxième question concerne un film
un peu étrange un peu marginale des
années 70 or il s'appelait admirable
week-end riche où le personnage
principal était en travelo encore on va
dire encore dans notre imaginaire mais
c'est pas vrai je lui fais pour l'effort
alors ses personnages [__]
sauvagement l'acteur principal de ce
drame
fédéric forest je voudrais savoir quel
est le nom de l'actrice qui jouait ce
personnage on faisait pipi debout sur le
bar elle s'appelait je n'ai pas voulu
dire ça mais voilà c'est ça oui c'est
vrai qu'à l'ouest
oui bonne réponse voilà alors ma
deuxième question va pour toi m'a vexé
question maintenant qui concerne plus
leur accorder mon amour va pour toi
alors brian wilson qui fait d'elle ex
même sociale ex musicien et chanteur du
groupe années 70 the beach boys après
quelques chants grégoriens usa il était
devenu obèse il est devenu fou en soi il
avait dérapé il a une fois les paradis
artificiels avait dérapé renfermé et là
ils viennent de sortir un album et vient
de créer un précédent dans l'histoire de
la musique qu'elle est sans précédent
qu'est-ce qui vient de réaliser pour ne
jamais vu par sécurité
je sais pas je suis là c'est vraiment ça
précédent il a fait son album avec son 6
4 il a écrit les chansons et 106 kg à
quoi il a enregistré avec son soutien
beaucoup mieux voilà je suis désolé je
me dis attendez d'écouté à l'afp
alors voilà la deuxième question il ya
d'habiles deroff man france
l'ex-chanteur des vandales
l'année dernière avait fait une
déclaration d'amour un peu certains ont
dit que les deux grossières
lui il a dit que l'été simplement
chaleureuse puisqu'il avait fait une
déclaration d'amour et un mineur son
sexe en touchant son sexe etc
à la télé américaine ait française et
européenne quel est le nom de cette
princesse quand m
oui c'était l'année dernière c'était
l'avenir oui ça pouvait pas être car au
lendemain michel ahnee stéphanie de
monaco
ce festival et monaco ball repos et
saufs
les questions d'ordre général et elle
est la personnalité rock jenny bel'air
quelle est la personnalité rock qui a
toujours dans son appartement une pièce
de 50 m² toujours à température de zéro
degrés toute l'année je sais parce que
elle est voulue avec mabri 7 pour
chanter justement vous chante quoi
réviser leur des jeunes
mais bon et avec les pour hugues j je
n'ai pas les impôts si yoko ono aux
bonnes réponses mais comment tu sais ça
lâche moi je le sais mais comment
pourquoi
et pourquoi au point une paire de
critères de saussure et d'une fourrure
aussi un très bon en fait une histoire à
tout cas une bonne réponse banal génie
toile à marie-france maintenant qu'elle
aussi était la rock star
3-2 quelle était la rock star qui louait
toujours les premiers étages de 747 dans
lesquelles il se déplacer pour que l'on
puisse puisse jouer avec son train
électrique pour qui son coin son fils
aux à son fils pourrait jouer à une
centrale électrique et loup est toujours
les premiers étages en se livrant des
radars une rock star était tout nouveau
abreuvoir wapstart en retard au culte à
rockstar jeudi radio hasard john lennon
oui oui bon on nous répond symbole
avant cela bien c'est exactement ça
d'écouter les 107 afrique à chaque fois
ses fils qui a gagné alors d'un droit
marie-france non 3 2 et en algérie
marie-france xhaka qui m'a éveillé chez
marie france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hall 10 de la semaine signée charbit
jason leur plus gros hits avec un got
you baby et sims aient la vie depuis
elle s'est fait refaire pas par lui mais
par le tout bio jackson
nahla d'haïti
[Musique]
mais est-ce que
ouais
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
ou de voix
la nature
ma dalton
[Musique]
or
ce qui passe
ouais
[Musique]
m
et
qui
[Musique]
nadal
ma belle à la gare
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui où
[Musique]
à
e
et oh
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
et vous
oui
[Musique]
non
oui
vous
[Musique]
ou aussi lui
non
tous
ouais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu